[Music]
all right so i have a story of a family
who is fighting to keep a photo of their
daughter
giving the finger on her gravestone
that is cool yeah so she's like going
like this and then
does she do it like this or is she this
one so this is what the gravestone looks
like
so she was she was 13 years old when she
died of
cystic fibrosis and this is the picture
so she's kind of like going like this
that's tight she's just a badass
yeah and so i got the bottom line
rip babe yeah rip babe but
yeah so she died in february of this
year
and so her gravestone has been there for
several months what's cystic fibrosis
what kind of cancers is that
it's of the lungs it's a disorder it's
not a cancer and then they get like a
fluid you can see it like fluid and then
it's like inherited
life-threatening disorder oh you're born
with it
yes so yeah like it's not maybelline
damn no it's not
it's not she's born with it
the more i thought about it it became
funnier in my head damn she's not
but yeah so she ended up um passing away
from
from that and yeah so anyway the
graystone has been there for many months
and there have been no issues but
recently
the family got a phone call from the
city council telling her that someone
put in a complaint about the picture
who's this karen ass [ __ ] what's the
male character
the picture's not even big you have to
like look close to like even
notice it right it's not like a giant
statue
you're keeping the place it looks like
it's picking her nose too if anything
but what if it's the neighbor like right
next to it aren't they blank
the ones the next one is like taro over
here they look like blank ones
what's with all these places that get
complaints and they they always follow
up on it
but then like if i lose a package or
something on the airline they're like
[ __ ] you we don't give a [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself that's what happened
your to your luggage
until you get on twitter and use your
social media powers to get
some service and then they treat you
like that's your only hope yeah
that's the only reason why i wanted to
be famous is so like
companies will actually talk to me there
you go you rat the [ __ ] out of them
yeah so anyway so yeah someone
complained about this picture
and so the they told her like the mom
they told her that they are willing to
swap the picture free of charge but
the mom is like no i have no sympathy
for the person that was offended
they don't have to look at it i lost my
13 year old daughter i picked that
picture for a reason it represents her
if you don't like it don't look at it
true now we have to deal with with this
[ __ ]
yeah so they're just kind of like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
[ __ ] anonymous complaints they need to
[ __ ] argue it out yeah say it to my
face then
right so maybe just pull up her picture
and make it bigger
and then put that on top of the
tombstone
yeah make it even larger yeah yeah yeah
make a statement make a statue of her
yeah
make a statue like this make it bigger
than these guys yo do it go for me
let's still go for me to get a statue of
her to replace that tombstone or we're
going like this
i love it i love it dude let's do let's
go even further
let's rename the graveyard whatever the
[ __ ] it is to [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you cemetery yeah
instead of rose hills it's [ __ ] you
cemetery
hell yeah damn they're gonna get no
business
where's your grandma [ __ ] you oh i'm
sorry no no no she's at [ __ ] you
i can't believe people who already have
to deal with such crazy [ __ ] like
somebody having cystic fibrosis dying
very young
now they gotta deal with this [ __ ]
they want to remember remember her for
something you know funny right it's
probably someone
who has someone in that graveyard you
know
and i'm i'm assuming it's one of the
neighbors i am i'm assuming
because you gotta it like i saw little
crosses or whatever next to the next
door right so it's
as soon as i'm assuming that it's
someone that put like something down on
the ground looked up and said what the
[ __ ] this girl's
doing this mm-hmm so just a little hint
for you
it's probably one of those [ __ ] i'm
writing them out yep yeah
and i'll just hit them up i'll be like
yo is this the whatever family you got
some [ __ ]
say to my face [ __ ] they're like yeah
they're like no and y'all started to
bother you let me call someone else
you're like what
no he just goes through the entire
cemetery calling all the families say
tomorrow
face [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh you can't
it can't be against the rules right
there's no rules that say like i know
right
you can't i mean they approved it in the
beginning it's the smallest little
picture i've ever seen in my whole life
yeah and you're paying for it so i don't
know why the other person is being
it's not like you painted your house
pink and i'm your neighbor
and then they say this means different
things in different languages too so
it's like yeah
what does it mean i don't know just what
i heard her i think it means [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] you different versions i mean
it's one of those things where like
people don't want to explain [ __ ] to
their kids so they're like
when we're visiting grandma at the grave
i don't want to explain to my
five-year-old
what the middle finger means and be like
i'll be like
i would they tell me when you're going
next time i'll explain it to her
they say that but then i see parents at
the grocery store or like at target
and their kid like has something and
they're holding it right and then they
get to the checkout and their parents
like oh look at that and then they take
it out of their hand and it just
disappears
and then it's gone and the kid doesn't
even know what the [ __ ] going on
they know how to trick their kid like
that but they don't they don't want to
have to explain something like it's as
stupid as [ __ ]
[ __ ] you means making a baby but in a
bad way
that's right i don't know if i i'll
define it like that
yeah why do we say [ __ ] you like that
because when you think about it it's
like sex you yes yeah it's weird right
true look at the origins i want to have
sex with you
you're trying to just wish wish upon
someone yeah but then you're saying [ __ ]
you it's like
oh thank you wow i hope i get some yeah
it's one of the best words in the
english language feel so good
yeah if you're bilingual or um if you if
you if you're a manic origin yeah it's
been around for a while
i researched the history of it it's
related to dutch
german and swedish what do they say
to strike and to move back and forth
like [ __ ] irish say folks how conor
mcgregor that's how i do it
what the [ __ ] is that guys you [ __ ]
loser
oh it's like if someone calls you a
[ __ ] you know how that offensive i'm
like damn i'm wet
yeah dude and powerful i'm something i'm
something i've been chasing my whole
life
and it could take a beating damn take
can take the deepest beatings
yeah maybe that's why you're a [ __ ]
because you're always taking beatings
that's pretty good i tried googling what
the middle finger means for other places
well i googled um
what did i google i put does the middle
finger mean
and then you know how to like oh any
suggestions it said
to me that you hate god or that you go
to
you're going to hell i thought those i
just picture like a four-year-old like
or five-year-old
googling this [ __ ] what does this mean
yeah mommy won't tell me google will
yeah but anyway it says that the finger
does not have any meaning at all in some
parts of the country
this country the us not the us uh like a
walk into oklahoma
and germany i used to get my grandma to
take the world
i had my grandma take pictures with me
like this i [ __ ] love these fingers
i'll be like do this grandma this is
like every take pictures like this 16
year old girl's birthday party photo
that's true
[ __ ] off college parties
like a drink now [ __ ] i'm bad oh it
says although the finger has been
called the universal sign of disrespect
it is not truly universal for example in
japanese sign language
when the palm is facing out it is
recognized as the character
set many other gestures are used
through japan my grandma used to point
with her middle finger
like she'll she'll point at stuff on the
book with her middle finger a lot of
people do that my grandpa too
yeah oh yeah in russia the middle finger
his finger the middle finger used
to simply point that is how i press
buttons one of my favorite traditional
photos is just a dude
a dude with the beer and you've all seen
this picture it's like
yeah guy with a chunk of beer flipping
off the camera
that's some cultural [ __ ] right that is
huh it's kind of like the peace sign
dude it's like peace oh crazy did you
know there was a
v sign in the commonwealth of nations
countries except
canada the v sign is an insult the
middle and index fingers raised and
given
with the back of the hand towards the
recipient serves a similar
purpose to the finger the v sign with
palm face
outwards instead of in is a sign of
peace
so this is bad this is good and this is
p
wow this feels better though because
this feels like my finger is way
more erect like
so far back it's like exposed it's like
naked
yeah [ __ ] you you know the piece
the cheese piece yeah it's supposed like
the cheese like that
like this is a victory sign v peace out
dude my
my right middle finger isn't as flexible
as my left one you know this one is
another one
it's direct like crazy this one's not
that correct i got a picture with mine
another one yes that one [ __ ] you what
is that whose nose do you have
the sign of the horns or corners italian
horned hand is a gesture with various
meanings depending on culture context or
the placement or movement of the gesture
it is especially common in italy and the
mediterranean region where it generally
takes on two different meanings
depending on context and positioning of
the hand
first it's a very small dick how about
the [ __ ] okay that's what it means
oh they do it like this
that was really good thank you what does
this mean oh just double that that means
[ __ ] me tonight while i [ __ ] you back
oh dang cause it is double middle finger
that means let's go butt to butt and
jerk each other off
let's put that behind our butt cheeks
and stick it into our asses
oh in grease five fingers are spread
wide and the palm is pushed towards
someone in
in a gesture known as a mutsa the middle
finger is still used though and is
considered more insulting
another variation of the middle finger
is used where all the fingers but the
middle one are separated
wide so let's just talk to the hand this
one's offensive everywhere because if
you push it to their face
just like hey talk to the [ __ ] hand
dude you don't know if they're like
trying to insult you or slap you in the
face
wikipedia is so interesting guys i love
you you get to learn so many such a
good source of dependable knowledge this
is also called iron man
yeah this also talk to the hand the face
don't understand right did you know in
former persia
mainly iran and iraq a gesture involving
exposing only the thumb in a vertical
orientation
which is a thumbs up is used instead of
the finger to express
roughly the same sentiment roughly
equivalent in meaning to shove it up
your ass
or up yours or go [ __ ] yourself well
this is that oh yeah i've seen that
where they go like that
i've never put my middle finger up as an
insult to somebody
you haven't oh it's fun when you're
driving yeah i do it all the time when
i'm driving do you not drive in los
angeles california
i'm a peaceful driver wow i'm not in
some arab countries
this gesture bears negative vulgar or
offensive meanings as well
okay jester um isn't this watching too
it just means offensive in contrast to
japan's use of the expression to
represent
coins and wealth the gestures oh shape
stands for zero meaning worth nothing in
france
belgium and tunisia this is walgreens
shopper
you have to stand in a big [ __ ] line
this is how you say no
in japanese really or you don't have it
really
it's a big x i think that's how you say
no everything i would say
yeah yeah no english oh yeah no yeah no
english
true i like how in japan you like you do
this
for like how many yeah two people three
people
three people how do you do ten people i
don't know
this is how you say i'm not catholic in
a church
you do when they like go up and bless
you or whatever yeah yeah just like
what does that mean really say like hey
i'm i'm going don't put that holy water
on me oh yeah like taking the communion
or white yeah
when yeah when they call you up to do
that because everyone's coming up
so they eat the little papers that just
means you don't want to take it
right it just means you don't want to
take it i'll take it's free food i'm not
catholic i take it every time i want to
take it too
the welch's grape juice and that little
brick is [ __ ] good dude
there's no alcohol in there i don't
drink alcohol in the first place there
used to be when jesus christ was walking
around
well anyway i hope kayla's family um are
able to keep
the photo in the gravestone that go fund
me i think yo let's build a [ __ ] you
statue
let's replace it with like a video
billboard of her just like going
yeah absolutely a gif a jiff
[Music]
you